I've just modified this Microwave Oven Transformer
into a dangerous little device. 800 amps of
electrical current is about to be bad news
for anything made of metal.
Today I'm in the mood to melt some metal.
This Microwave Oven Transformer used to be
a dangerously high-voltage device, but I modified
it so the voltage is extremely low, and it's
the amps now that are insanely high. High
enough that when the electrodes touch this
screw, it melts into a little ball of steel.
This time I've hooked it up to a machine screw
for melting, and when it heats up it changes
color and the outer layer bursts into flames.
If I hold the electrodes in constant contact,
you can see molten metal flowing down the
screw, and within seconds it's completely
gone. I just love the way these light up and
flash, throwing off sparks as they melt. This
bolt is longer so it's taking more time to
melt. You can see an array of color changes
as the metal heats up to the point where it
begins to glow a burning bright orange. Back
on my workbench, you can see the input voltage
to the primary coil is about 120 volts AC,
which is typical mains power in my area. And
with this modified secondary, you can see
I've stepped the potential down to only 3
volts. The voltage is so low that I can actually
touch the live wires with bare hands, and
not feel anything. Even though the power being
generated is enough to completely incinerate
this wood screw on contact. This much power
has the potential to kill you, so don't ever
try this yourself. Now here's a 5/16" bolt
I'm trying to melt, and it's building up so
much heat that my 4 gauge electrode wires
are smoking. As it's cooling, I'll try a little
amateur blacksmithing while I have the chance,
because this got so hot, I just melted my
melter. 4 gauge wires just aren't enough to
handle the extreme current pumping through
these wires. That's ok though because the
primary coil is still good, so I'll just rip
off the secondary so I can use the rest of
this in another project, like making a makeshift
stick welder. Look for that in a future video.
In the meantime, I still have this other MOT
that was salvaged from a microwave in a previous
project, and after making the proper modifications,
I've got a new metal melter sporting this
thicker 2 gauge wire. To fire it up, I'll
attach input wires to the primary coil, plug
those into a power bar, and flip on the switch.
You can see the low voltage sparks off the
terminals, and I'm measuring their potential
at just over 2 volts. Once again, for your
entertainment, I'm holding the leads bare
handed, and you can clearly see there's power
to the system because of the electrical arcing.
There's also a visible amount of current pumping
through this screw. The thicker wire should
be able to handle higher temperatures than
the first, so I'm gonna experiment on various
items around the house, like this iron nail.
And a drywall screw. How about some lead solder.
Or a zinc washer. And various other objects
made of metal. One friend suggested I try
melting a padlock and that seemed like a fun
idea. It's at full power and the steel retaining
clip is getting extremely hot, but the metal
isn't melting. Something inside the casing
just caught fire though, and although the
retaining clip isn't melting, the lock is
so hot that the clip just fell open. Along
with the rest of it. I'll try a couple of
amateur spot welds on some stainless steel,
and i'm impressed at how much effort it takes
to get them to break. When experimenting with
an aluminum can, the electrodes cut through
the metal like butter, but this thicker aluminum
disc won't glow at all. I'm not sure how hot
it is but when I drip water on it, the water
is instantly boiled and vaporized. I did get
this steel coin pretty hot, and if it will
do that, i'm wondering what it will do to
steel wool. Amazingly, nothing happens unless
the electrodes are so close they're almost
touching. Aluminum foil isn't very exciting
either, but I've managed to reduce this sheet
down to a little blob of metal. I've got some
Neodymium magnets ready, but the voltage is
too low to get through all eight. However,
if tap onto two, it seems to be working really
well. They're getting so hot they've gone
totally incandescent, and apparently have
just been liquified. These are among the worlds
strongest magnets, but after exposure to temperatures
over 300ºC, they lose most of their magnetic
properties. Here's a large steel nut that's
harder to heat, but in the end it glows very
nicely as well. This one's just got so hot
that it's exploding liquid metal. As expected,
I got no visible reactions from a 250 volt
lightbulb, or this audio transformer. But
I did have a lot of fun melting down the tines
on this fork. This brings back memories of
curling plastic forks over the fire as a kid.
It's not very useful anymore, but it looks
pretty neat. I'm applying a current to the
underside of this knife and can visibly see
the point of contact. The whole blade is glowing
and this is looking really cool. At this point,
the blade is really easy to bend. For my last
trick, I got a circuit board with some high
temperature solder that my desoldering iron
wouldn't melt. But hooking a couple of nails
to the electrodes gives me the ability to
instantly liquify the solder on these contact
points.. Well we cheated death again and destroyed
a lot of metal doing it. If you like these
videos, you can support me by becoming a subscriber
and sharing with your friends. I appreciate
your support. Thanks for watching.